you
don't share your lips
I don't kill who
how you can get up and get dressed and
bless yourself with showing you nothing
don't spill your drinks I'm not
impressed oh not a bit get up thing get
some ink write down what I feel is what
I think
no God in the home knows fear
- foot pain sighs heaven
what a big uns no no one is ever ready
you
take you things and have them nothing
else will come I know that you are dying
and who you are is done
know that you are living and how many
were before sing for the sake of singing
and don't
No
broken watch does not stop time
war is always tasty scission
nothing will ever be my yen
and this song is a invention
very urgent
so my or overall it's good morning
evening it's once or is small but the
name how what's my name yeah what's my
name again when I held up the roof the
floor would cave in
shadowboxing mano Lago we talk when we
talk we talk shadowboxing Malaga weewawk
weewawk weewawk weewawk
Scriven and caffeine a line in the wind
busy with only your sand castles in
what's the name hell what's the name you
what's my name again when held of the
room floor would Kevin shadowboxing you
told me to
cool tall shadow boxing
all shadowboxing
train
angling shadowbox and mom
we dream
we dream we dream we dream
we dream we train and it's not
we are we say we sculptured I start you
to worship a man casts thoughts behind
the glass
Oh
shadowboxing Manalo and we Ted Tom
in Berlin this project weighed all and
we were in a poll Ian cut and disposed
and I wish I were two little dogs on the
log so I could play with each other
the question that comes to my head and
should I watch one two pipe and no
commemorate dead millions and trillions
who have never had any time
and apparently stars [ __ ] the stone in
your hand is holding your hand and I do
understand and I don't understand I just
wish I could stand in the middle of a
mountain when I dream cups empty when I
move I'm tough
when I think of a girl in the world I
know she won't be enough
city life
she loved
forever
if there's not still up by myself open
and bleeding a lot and seeing Madonna
showing the spots I take a bow to the
women and bales when I drink up some tea
when I move I am tough when I think of a
boy in the world I know he won't be
enough
shitty love
city love
you
city
[ __ ] [ __ ] shitty listen city lights a
city I see city lights I said city
necessar
City forever
thank you very much thank you very much
we want to sing a song in Swiss German
and if history would have been different
than then this whole conference might as
well be in Swiss German and and and you
know you would have had Swiss German in
school and you would say to your
children if you want to be someone in
life you have to definitely learn Swiss
German unless so this is uh this is what
what this conference would sound like
oh gosh trash but new to makes a and C
toxic the how near murdered me
Oh gasps Tristan speak of a borough on
sit har play this safe awesome not
he be not anything for did solving dos
then on blue snow Danny died for me
solve it Nixie Blue Monster skeptic hi
Anstis gafty admin Emma leave
mean doc the sytem dr. Mantlo the exact
Apple drummed pin in it neat mean doc
decide who like the montolo on the exact
overdrawn der honey neat nothing been he
be not any therefore solving do see fish
fun to Snowden it I solve a nice blue
monsters gap T hi
Vance's cavity Varma Amuro Ally
singing and playing the guitar from
Zurich Christian brother singing and
playing the glockenspiel and playing the
trombone from Zurich me Heil
Florie
running countryside mountains being kind
we shifting times when you wanna follow
the you one general collision with all
that stands as such we reinvent we
pteropod stitch and Stitch watching van
spray perfume floods the streets and
everyone is thinned and the crowd inside
of me but all this hell
to you does not
ah
I
Oh
let me win
yeah
nothing with the chain
you
you
I'm talking to the man in mirror and I'm
asking him to change his ways no message
could have been any better if you want
to make the world that's a place better
look at yourself and then you make Jay
Jay Jay
you
stranor wait 800 focus balance on top
culpa hey hey nothing bangs winner
hey hey our MOOC is Latin Songs yeah
cool but hey hey anything back so shovel
lunch if I travel and you find a bunch
of I haven't launched a fighter trip
hey uh um go keys bands homes your coma
Deanna Dewberry na nee Harbin kokis
wagons hums your Cora he anithing boxes
shovel mirja Fat Bob emerge if I have an
amount you find clever merger father
Vaughn
you
Oh
my show
son
for nothing more mature but all of us
all of this still does not but all of
the shout of this to you does not but
all this to you
to stop
you
investment in broadband high-speed
Internet can help small businesses
create new American jobs small
businesses are being formed dreams are
being launched and at AT&T we're
investing billions to upgrade and build
out our wired and wireless networks now
is not the time to stall momentum or
stifle innovation or investment jobs
dreams and the future are at stake
AT&T your world delivered